supongamos que mis amigos y yo vamos a
una cafetería y se nos ocurre una idea
buenísima la de vender calcetines por
internet déjale cómo jugar aquí
calcetines calcetines
por internet por
internet
net ok entonces estamos súper
emocionados ya tenemos muy buenas ideas
para que esto pegue y lo siguiente que
tenemos que hacer es empezar una
compañía claro primero hay que escribir
un poquito un plan de negocios para ver
cómo van a estar los números y así pero
y bueno esto lo podemos hacer en
cualquier orden eventualmente tenemos
que hacer una hoja de balance para ver
cómo empieza todo entonces déjame
dibujar una hoja de balance recuerda que
a la izquierda va el activo lo que son
beneficios futuros para la empresa ya la
derecha va el pasivo para entonces voy a
dibujar aquí a la izquierda un
rectángulo que va a hacer
el activo de nuestra empresa
y entonces estos son beneficios futuros
para la empresa pero como ahorita nada
más tenemos la idea lo único que tenemos
en activo es ideal bueno a lo mejor
puedes decir que también aquí en parte
del activo es el talento que nosotros
tenemos mis amigos y yo entonces ya
tenemos una idea y ya tenemos talento y
esto es el lado izquierdo de la hoja de
balance que es el activo pero al lado
derecho hay te recomiendo repasarlos los
vídeos de hoja de balance si es que no
los has visto porque de esta forma vas a
entender mucho mejor lo que estoy
haciendo en este vídeo va entonces aquí
a la izquierda está el activo y a la
derecha va el pasivo y el capital pero
el pasivo son obligaciones y préstamos
que nos ha hecho el banco y cosas por el
estilo entonces hasta ahorita no tenemos
nada de pasivo para entonces de este
lado tendría que ir el pasivo y el
capital pero no hay nada de pasivo y de
este modo todo lo de la derecha va a ser
capital
voy a poner con este color azul
entonces esto de acá es el capital
capital
recuerda que siempre cuando tenemos una
hoja de balance hay una ecuación que se
debe de satisfacer que es que activo sea
igual a pasivo más capital más capital
como aquí el pasivo es cero no hemos
tenido ningún préstamo del banco
entonces el activo es igual al capital
bueno pero ya que tenemos pues esta idea
y el talento y su capital
correspondiente pues mis amigos y yo
queremos de alguna forma dividirnos este
capital de manera equitativa entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es hacer esto por
escrito cómo hacemos esto pues vamos a
emitir algunas acciones entonces déjame
ponerle por aquí que emitimos digamos un
millón de acciones van acciones
y como cada uno de nosotros colaboró de
manera igual para la idea y consideramos
que tenemos el mismo talento entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es dividir este millón
de acciones en cinco personas en cinco
cachos lo voy a dividir por aquí el
capitán con algunas líneas horizontales
ahí van cinco divisiones y entonces pues
aquí tendríamos 200.000 acciones acá
también tendríamos 200 mil le voy a
poner una acá que es de 1000 van otras
200 mil 200 mil
y 200.000 aquí tenemos déjame apartar
esta parte cita de acá y vamos a suponer
que esta es mi parte va ahorita va a
saber porque le estoy separando ahorita
platicamos eso pero bueno entonces ya
tenemos un activo un capital dividido
pero hasta ahorita nuestro activo solo
es idea y talento y pues no podemos
hacer gran cosa con ideas y buenas
intenciones verdad realmente queremos
ponernos a vender calcetines por
internet y para que esto pegue pues
vamos a tener que empezar a diseñar una
página de internet a hablar con
maquiladoras para que nos empiecen a
hacer pues algunos descuentos verdad y
para esto necesitamos efectivo entonces
necesitamos conseguir dinero para poder
empezar a hacer nuestras operaciones
aquí es donde entra el mercado de
capital le voy a escribir por acá
mercado mercado de capital
capital y esto se refiere principalmente
a que a que queremos financiar nos pero
sin endeudarnos no queremos ir a un
banco y que nos cobren intereses sino
más bien queremos ir con algún
emprendedor que quiera prestar su dinero
ahora no cualquier emprendedor va a
querer prestar su dinero porque hay un
área muy específica del mercado de
capital que se dedica a las empresas que
están empezando y es el capital de
riesgo capital de riesgo
y más aún dentro del capital de riesgo
hay una sub clase de inversionistas por
así decirlo que son los que se dedican
más a invertir en negocios nuevos y en
ideas innovadoras y se llaman los
inversionistas ángeles inversionistas
le voy a poner aquí ángel a ángel y esto
de ángel suena súper padre porque suena
que tiene alas y abrió la y todo eso y
pues si tiene una idea o una historia
detrás que puedes buscar en wikipedia o
en internet pero ahorita nada más déjame
contarte de qué se trata un
inversionista ángel y bueno no no quiero
hablar mucho en términos de estereotipos
pero te los puedes imaginar como estos
pues viejos millonarios que les fue muy
bien en los años 80 que ahora tienen un
montón de dinero de sobra y que les
gusta invertirlo en los proyectos de la
gente joven como mis amigos y yo en esto
venden de 20 calcetines o en cualquier
otra idea loca que se te ocurra y así
pues te los puedes imaginar más o menos
como como tu tío millonario igual poner
entre comillas tu tío millonario bueno
no sé si tengas un tío millonario pero
imaginamos que imaginemos que lo tienes
que tu tío millonario que te da dinero
para gastarlo en ideas de negocios con
con tus amigos vale bueno entonces este
es el mercado de capital que nos
interesa queremos llegar con un
inversionista ángel y venderle la idea
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es de
este lado hacer un plan de negocios
hacer proyecciones hacer retorno sobre
la inversión estimado y entonces vamos a
ir con varios inversionistas ángel les
invitamos una comida les decimos sabes
que te vamos a regalar nueve pares de
calcetines para navidad y entonces vamos
a ir platicando con cada uno de ellos y
puede ser que los primeros nueve de diez
pues nos cierren la puerta en la cara y
nos digan que no que no les agrada la
idea pero al décimo a lo mejor tenemos
suerte y si finalmente encontramos un
inversionista que le interesa esto pues
de invertir en calcetines por internet
de abrir no sé de calcetines en línea
puntocom o lo que sea entonces pues ese
inversionista ya nos dijo que sí pero va
a empezar una cierta negociación
entonces lo primero que tiene que pasar
para que se dé esta negociación es que
entre el inversionista y nosotros
tenemos que llevar llegar a una
evaluación de esto que estamos
presentando va entonces lo primero
se tiene que hacer déjame ponerle por
aquí es una evaluación evaluación
previa
si te das cuenta hasta ahorita no le he
puesto nada de valor en en efectivo a
esto de acá porque tiene una razón
tenemos que esperarnos a la evaluación
previa porque no importa que digamos
nosotros vamos a tener que llegar a un
acuerdo con cualquier inversionista
entonces no sé supongamos que el
inversionista de nuestra idea y dice
guau está súper buena yo creo que vale
muchísimo la pena invertir aquí porque
es una idea fundamental para la economía
mexicana y entonces la evaluación previa
que hace el inversionista ángel y su
grupo de de analistas es que nuestra
idea vale 5 millones de pesos vale le
voy a poner aquí que esto vale 5
millones
y supongamos que para empezar nuestras
operaciones necesitamos cinco millones
en efectivo o sea cinco millones así ya
de dinero de billetes pues entonces qué
va a suceder el inversionista dice bueno
esto vale cinco millones yo estoy
dispuesto a poner esos cinco millones
déjame ponerle por acá éste mira el
color de inversionista ángeles es así
como un azul medio angelical dejamos ver
si es este creo que sí entonces el ahora
tema la evaluación previa es que la idea
y el talento vale cinco millones pero
luego el inversionista ángel
el inversionista ángel va a dar otros 5
millones pero ahora en efectivo
entonces ahora de alguna forma debemos
de indicar que el inversionista ángel
también forma parte de nuestra sociedad
de nuestra empresa y cómo lo vamos a
hacer pues le vamos a emitir acciones
déjame hacer esta idea un poco más
concretamente para que quede bien claro
cómo está y para esto voy a volver a
escribir esta hoja de balance que está
por aquí arriba sólo que un poco más
chiquita va entonces lo voy a poner algo
de este estilo
entonces ahí ya es la idea y el talento
vale la idea y el talento y estoy acá
según la evaluación previa a la
inversión es de 5 millones
5 millones y luego el inversionista
ángel va a cooperar con otros 5 millones
en efectivo entonces aquí le pongo 5
millones
efe efectivo muy bien todavía no tenemos
nada de obligaciones porque el
inversionista solo es un socio no es no
es un prestamista entonces de todas
formas a la derecha seguimos teniendo el
mismo capital o bueno más bien todo
sigue siendo capital van
a esta capital aquí está la división de
las acciones nuestras y del
inversionista ángel y aquí voy a poner
las subdivisiones de las acciones de mis
amigos y yo sale por acá está la mía la
voy a indicar na más hacia en color
morado y recordemos que son 200 mil
acciones entonces estas son 200 mil
todas estas décadas son un millón las de
mis amigos y yo entonces cuánto
tendríamos que emitir para darle las
acciones pues justas al inversionista
ángel pues ve estos cinco millones de
pesos en efectivo cuánto valen pues no
es una pregunta con truco realmente
valen 5 millones verdad y acá abajo
dijimos que la idea vale también 5
millones
de este modo para que todo esté justo
para que lleguemos a un acuerdo lo que
tendríamos que hacer nosotros como mesa
directiva mis amigos y yo como mesa
directiva de esta empresa que está
empezando sería emitir otro millón de
acciones para el inversionista ángel y
es justo lo que tiene sentido verdad
porque está colaborando con un tanto
igual que el que nosotros estamos
colaborando y esto ya está padre porque
así en nuestros activos ya tenemos una
idea talento y efectivo con que trabajar
y del lado del capital ya están
divididas las cosas equitativamente y
realmente este es de las únicas formas
en las cuales en las cuales se puede
empezar a hacer una empresa así con una
idea innovadora porque por ejemplo si
fuéramos a un banco si quisiéramos esto
de acá que fuera un pasivo más bien
déjame ponerle que es capital para que
no nos
y confundamos esto ya que es capital
todo este lado es activo
todo esto de acá
pero si fuéramos a un banco y
quisiéramos financiarnos con deuda o sea
que nos hicieran un préstamo para darles
este ciertos intereses anuales y así y
les decimos sabes que queremos abrir
calcetines en línea puntocom porque es
una idea buenísima y va a tener
muchísimas veces no nos van a decir que
no sea la que prácticamente nos van a
cerrar la puerta en la cara porque al
banco lo que le interesa es financiar a
negocios que ya estén funcionando porque
ellos si tienen un flujo de efectivo con
el cual pueden pagar sus intereses bueno
hay un par de ideas más que quiero
contarte ahorita nada más me va a dar
tiempo de una la primera es acerca de si
se diluyen o no las acciones y la
segunda es qué pasa cuando el
inversionista ángel cuando el
inversionista ángel pues negocia un poco
más fuertemente entonces con respecto a
la dilución de acciones muchas personas
hablan de esto en los periódicos y así y
aquí podría aparecer que tenemos un
fenómeno de dilución de acciones por qué
porque fíjate al inicio yo ahora bueno
puesto es importante que marcar esta
parte yo empecé teniendo 200.000
acciones de un millón entonces al
principio
al principio déjame ponerlo este 2 por
acá bajito vale al principio teníamos
una evaluación previa evaluación previa
de la cual yo tenía 200.000 acciones
y por tanto como yo tenía 200.000 de un
millón de acciones tenía un quinto de
todo va pero según nuestra evaluación
posterior a esto todavía no lo he
mencionado verdad la evaluación
posterior es este pues cuánto vale en la
empresa ya después de que el
inversionista copero y si no y no es
difícil verdad aquí tenemos una
evaluación posterior evaluación
posterior de 10 millones 10 millones
pero perdón ahora sí con la evaluación
posterior nos regresamos para acá y en
la evaluación posterior que sucede yo
sigo teniendo 200.000 acciones 200.000
pero ahora no de un millón sino de dos
millones entonces ahora pasó a tener un
décimo de toda la empresa entonces
parece que lo que yo tengo se fue a la
mitad pero ojo ahora aquí bueno aquí
tenía un quinto de cinco millones o sea
tenía algo que valía un millón pero acá
tengo un décimo de diez millones
sigo teniendo algo que vale un millón
entonces realmente en el fondo o al
menos en cantidad pues no ha habido una
dilución de lo que yo tengo
digamos en valor vale
bueno pues esa es la idea que te quería
contar en la siguiente vamos a ver qué
sucede si el inversionista ángel quiere
negociar más fuertemente y cree que
nuestra idea vale menos porque igual los
cinco millones de efectivo los vamos a
necesitar para las operaciones entonces
en realidad este porcentaje de acciones
tiene más que ver con la evaluación
previa de nuestra idea y del talento
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo para
explicarte estas cosas hasta la próxima